- During the six years
I worked at McKinsey,
I learned one question
that lots of consultants
use all the time in
order to lead their work
towards insights that are really
helpful for the companies,
and this is a question that
especially senior consultants,
such as partners or senior project leads,
would use in order to motivate their team,
in order to really drill
down into the insights
that the team generated,
and this is the question of the "So what?"
It's a question that is barely
used outside of consulting,
but in consulting, people
use it all the time.
Welcome to this channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
And if you take any value
out of this video at all,
please press the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also hit the Subscribe button below
as well as turn on the notifications
so that you get directly informed
whenever I release a new video.
I have at least video coming
out every week on Saturdays
and often I even post two or three video.
So if you'd like to stay informed,
hit the Subscribe button.
In these times, I hope all of you
are feeling healthy and safe.
Here in Germany,
at least the weather is
marvelous at the moment.
I just spent some time in the
garden today to relax a bit
and relieve myself of all the stress.
I hope you're also having a bit of time
to just wind down this weekend,
really focus on the things
that matter for you,
your family, and your community.
So the secret consulting technique
I'm talking about in this video
is the power of the question "So what?"
The power of the "So what?"
So why is this a question
that is extremely powerful
and helpful in your work, not
only if you're a consultant,
but also working in any
other professional job?
And in order to understand
what is so special about this question,
let's first dig in to what a typical day
in a corporate environment looks like.
You will have lots of
meetings with colleagues
from your department or
from other department.
You will receive data.
You will then conduct
analysis based on the data.
You will then probably prepare the results
in some kind of documents,
whether it's in Word,
PowerPoint, or maybe
even an Excel analysis.
And then in one way or another,
you will discuss this
work with your supervisor,
with your team lead,
with other colleagues,
and all of them reiterate,
and then, finally,
come to a result that's beneficial
to whatever task you were working on.
So while being a project lead at McKinsey,
I noticed that there
is one thing that many,
especially of the more junior
colleagues, struggle with,
and this is really
understand what the purpose
of a certain task they
were asked to do is.
What this leads to then
is that this junior colleague
will work on a certain task,
and he will think that it's
completed, and it's just fine,
because he did exactly
what he was asked to do,
but then when you review
it, when you look into it,
it might even be the case that,
yes, this was what you're asked to do,
but then this activity
that in the end turned out
to not really solve the question at hand,
to not really provide answers
to the issues that
you're actually raising.
But the junior consultant didn't realize
because he didn't really understand
why he was doing a specific thing,
but he just tried to
follow the instructions
as closely as possible because
probably he has in his head,
"Well, if I'm asked to
do this specific thing
"and then if I do this specific
thing, then it's okay."
But frequently you find out
that while you're doing a certainly thing,
even though initially you were asked
to do it in a certain way,
this way just doesn't make sense.
You will also need to maybe look
at traditional data and combine it,
maybe conduct another interview
that you didn't plan to do beforehand.
But then instead of
calling the other colleague
and asking the questions that
obviously would be needed
in order to really solve the problem,
you just don't do it
because this is not what
your direct supervisor
or your team lead asked you initially
when giving you a specific task.
And, of course, this is
subpar because by doing that,
the iterations on your work needed,
you will need to go back to the desk,
then work on it again,
then maybe compile the additional data,
the additional information.
Potentially you repeat certain activities
to then only review it again.
So how does the question of the "So what?"
come into play here?
And what's important to understand here
is that the main objective of consultants
is to derive insights,
to derive conclusions
from analysis that you conduct
that have a real business value
for the company you work for.
One of the biggest arguments
that you can get from your team lead
or maybe from partner
of your consultant firm
after you complete an analysis
is that this person says to you,
"Wow, thank you, that
was really insightful."
Being insightful is one of the best things
somebody can say about you in
such a corporate environment
because this means that
you helped the person
really come to a conclusion
that he otherwise would not have derived.
It means that your analysis
is so full of insights,
full of valuable conclusions,
that it really provide a value
to the people you are working for.
So what does this have
to do with a consultant
who just followed order
but didn't really come up
with a great result and
answers to questions?
Well, what this means
is that this consultant
did not really derive the
insights by doing his work
that he was suppose to come up with.
His work was not really insightful
even though he might have followed exactly
the things he was asked to do.
And consultants use one test to understand
whether your analysis, whether your work,
was insightful or not,
and it's a bit of a thought experiment,
and it asks you to
imagine yourself sitting
in a large boardroom with
all the C-level executives
of the company you're working for,
and then you present your results,
and then the CEO of the company asks you,
"What is the 'So what?'
of what you are doing?
"What is the 'So what?' Of your analysis?"
And these are just some
other words for asking,
"Well, what are the insights?
"What do I learn from your
analysis for my company?
"What conclusions can I
draw from your analysis
"for the things, the problems,
that I want to solve?"
The principle of the "So what?"
is so powerful that it is both useful,
on the one hand side,
for your communication,
both oral and written communication,
but also for how you structure your work
on a day-to-day basis.
So let's dive into the communication.
As you know, especially if
you're a visitor of my channel,
in corporate environments,
very frequently you will use PowerPoint
to visualize and structure
the results of your work.
And from very own experience,
I can tell you that
there is a big tendency
if you receive lots of
data as a consultant,
and then if you do
analyze and organize it,
there's a big natural tendency for you
to then just create lots of
PowerPoint pages out of it
because you want to show
some results of your work.
You put lots of time into
working with the data
so there also needs to be
some visible output out of there, right?
And this leads to then
creating a large document
of chart after chart, after chart,
visualizing what customer
structure the companies have,
the geographies the
companies is working in,
all kinds of cuts of the data
that you then prepare
for your team to look at.
But now as a project lead,
the question that you ask is "So what?"
So dear analyst,
dear associate now working
for me here on my team,
it's great that you look
into all these things
so that you prepared
this very big document,
but what are the so whats
that we can take out of your analysis?
This is then where especially
junior consultants struggle,
and then their work falls short
of what is actually needed and expected
because they created some
potentially great-looking pages.
They spent lots of time
analyzing all the data
that they get from the client,
but all this work did not
lead to any tangible so whats.
It didn't lead to any valuable
and actionable insights
that the client can achieve.
So what can you do to make sure
that both your oral and
written communication
always contains a strong "So what?"
And especially in written communication,
if you work in PowerPoint,
the so called action
title is the main tool
to use in order to convey your "So what?"
The action title should precisely
contain the "So what?" of
the page that you create.
And if you haven't seen it yet,
I created a video explaining
what an action title is
and how you come up with a good,
strong, powerful action title.
I will link it above
for you to check it out.
If you have not seen it yet,
I can highly recommend it.
And if you're really serious to learn
how to create slide
presentations in the same way
that large strategy
consulting firms do it,
I created a whole
multi-hour course on that.
I will leave a link in
the description below.
I have over 10,000
students taking the course
with lots of reviews for you to check out,
so have a look whether
this might be something
that might add value to you.
And besides the communication,
this powerful question of the "So what?"
can also help you guide and
prioritize your daily work.
Especially as a project leader,
it was my responsibility to lead the team,
the different associates
I was working with,
towards insights to what results
that were really helpful for the clients.
To achieve this,
we often had joint
problem solving questions,
asking ourselves, "What
are the things to do next?
"What analysis do we now want to do?"
and, "What do we hope to get out of it?
"What so whats?
"What implications do we
hope to get out of them?"
So this time is well spent
towards finding answers,
finding solutions for the
problems we were asked to solve.
So next time you work on
something, ask yourself,
"What problem am I really solving?
"Am I really creating insights here
"for the company I'm working for?
"What value can I add?
"What is the 'So what?' of my work?"
Ask yourself the questions, "So what?"
When you just created a
document, an analysis,
what do you get out of it?
What is the implication of
the things that you are doing?
So I sure hope that this video
had some good and
tangible so whats for you,
that there are some clear takeaways
and learnings for you
after watching this video.
If you don't know yet,
and I also have an Instagram account.
My Instagram handle is
@firmlearning as well,
so if you haven't see it
yet, please check it out.
Also on my Instagram,
I will do my very best
to provide fresh content for you
to help you succeed in the
first years of your career.
And, again, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please press the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and subscribe to the
channel to stay informed
and see all the latest
videos that I will release.
My promise to you is that I will release
at least one new video every week.
So stay healthy, keep learning,
thank you for watching.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.